okay so even though donald trump has
been completely missing from
being the president for what is now
several months
he did post another one of these bizarre
videos on new year's eve and this is a
particularly deranged video i showed it
to some mental health professionals and
said
if this person were a patient and came
into the office making claims like these
what would you think
and everybody i showed it to in some
version or another said
i would question whether the patient is
losing connection to reality
we'd be thinking about whether
medication is appropriate now that's not
a diagnosis of trump
it's a hypothetical about if trump was
on your couch rather than on your tv
making these claims what would you think
so let's get right into it
a very odd five-minute speech posted to
trump's twitter
on new year's eve trump not slurring in
this particular speech his voice does
sound
strained let's get right into it in the
face of great challenges this year
americans showed incredible grit
strength tenacity and resolve and
together we achieve truly historic
victories like
nobody ever thought possible to defeat
the china virus we launched the largest
mobilization since world war ii
we transformed our factories to build
tens of thousands of ventilators and
millions and millions
of masks virtually overnight nobody
thought it could be done
we ignored the experts who demanded open
borders
and we shut down travel from china and
europe to protect
our citizens and we built the wall so
this is trump's completely delusional
revisionist history on covid we've been
one of the biggest global failures
on covid we failed on testing we are
actively failing on vaccination which
we'll get to tomorrow
but this isn't new information we have
the seventh highest per capita cases in
the world
we have the 12th highest per capita
death rate in the world
excluding a couple tiny territories like
san marino and andorra if we include
them were 14th highest
i won't bore you with more of that
you're likely as sick of hearing about
those numbers
as i am and then just last thing trump
casually says we built the wall
no wall was built the promise was a wall
across the entire border by january 20th
there's two weeks left there's no wall
let's keep going
we pioneered groundbreaking new
therapies and treatments and we saved
millions of american lives
over and over again we were told it
would be impossible to deliver a vaccine
by the end of the year
all of the experts said absolutely
unthinkable
trump is exaggerating it can't happen
and we did it
long before the end of the year they
said it would take a medical miracle
and that's exactly what it is years from
now they'll be talking about it they'll
be talking about this great great thing
that we did
with the vaccines a truly unprecedented
amazing medical miracle normally
developing a vaccine takes up to 10
years
thanks to operation warp speed we
developed a vaccine
in just nine months now the lies there
are a bit more nuanced no one said
this is a straw man no one said you
can't do a vaccine by the end of the
year and in fact you can go back to my
shows
in late april and early may and i showed
you
uh sober projections one was i believe
from goldman sachs which think what you
want about them when it comes to these
these uh um timelines they've been
pretty good um
and they said we we expect an emergency
use vaccine
sometime in november and health care
vaccinations could start at the end of
november or early december
that ended up being the case so it's not
nobody was saying we'd have a vaccine
this year
but remember that trump promised us a
hundred million doses by the end of 2020
that failed he then definitely promised
us 20 million vaccinated by the end of
2020
we are only now getting to the first
four and a half five million doses
first dose given remember you need two
doses so
operation warp speed has fallen about 90
percent short of what was promised and
that's the bottom line
fact and then here trump really gets
even more delusional
we've already begun a nationwide
vaccination program
and we're sending the vaccine all over
the world
the world will benefit will benefit and
everybody's calling to thank me
we know of no calls from world leaders
thanking trump zero we know of zero
calls
but that's not really the big part to
talk about trump says
we're sending the vaccine all over the
world
that's about five layers of lies first
many of the vaccines have nothing to do
with operation
warp speed it's pharmaceutical companies
that are sending the vaccine all over
the world number two
trump turned down 100 million doses of
the pfizer vaccine in late july
so the hundred million doses were then
sold by
pfizer to other countries we're not
sending them
we turned them down so pfizer sold them
to somebody else
we could have had them trump said no and
now
pfizer has figured out that other
countries want them and they're sending
them elsewhere
so just wrong on four or five different
levels
let's keep going trump then singing his
praises and grading himself
we will end the pandemic once and for
all this is one of the most
extraordinary scientific
industrial and medical feats in history
everybody has it as that
that's what they're marketed down as and
we can never let people forget
where it came from and how it came trump
continues to be obsessed with his
marks as he calls them says that the
world has
marked this down as a major success
of course we have the pfizer biontech
vaccine
thanks to turkish immigrants in germany
the moderna vaccine
overseen by israeli-born chief medical
officer tal zaks
and french businessman ceo stefan
bonsell
who's the ceo of moderna and we have the
oxford vaccine
developed in oxford england starting to
be approved
what is trump talking about skipping
ahead a little bit here
um trump touts his great economy and
then he goes into some real whoppers
about the gdp which we've been warning
you about for a while
our economy is growing at the most rapid
rate ever recorded
33.4 percent last quarter and much
faster than the nations of europe nobody
can compete with us
this one is just sad we had rapid gdp
growth in the third quarter after record
gdp loss in the second quarter
if you have ten apples and i take away
seven and then give you six back and
brag about how no one's
ever given you more apples than me i'm
kind of an idiot right nobody would fall
for that but people are falling for the
equivalent story that donald trump is
telling
and of course it's similar with europe
europe is seeing
slower gdp growth because they had less
gdp decline to begin with understand it
so it's a total farce and donald trump
rapidly approaching
his last and final public appearances
tonight in georgia in support of the two
republican candidate candidates there
i'll be covering it live
i hope you'll join me on youtube twitch
and or facebook you can stream it on all
three at once if you want
uh starting about 8 30 p.m eastern time
tonight
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience 20
off lucy is a company founded by cal
tech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020 it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier
you'll find a ton of excellent reviews
online from countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just
a quick disclaimer i'm required to give
these products contain
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical